Let's say I've got a rope.
That's my rope.
And what I'm going to do is, I'm
going to take the left end
of the rope, and I'm going
to jerk it up,
and then back down.
And we're going to talk about
what happens or what possibly
gets formed.
So if I take it up over here,
it's going to, obviously, take
the string to the right
of it up with it.
And the string is going to
look something like this.
It's going to look something
like that.
Now I'm going to immediately
jerk it back down.
And as it passes, let's see what
the rope will look like
when the left-hand point is at
its original position again.
So the left-hand point-- I've
pulled it back down.
But in the last time period,
this part of the rope had some
type of an upward velocity.
You could imagine that way.
And even after that point, even
though this left-hand
point starts getting pulled
down, this point right here
still has some upward
momentum.
So it's still going to keep
moving up, maybe at a slower
pace because it's starting
to be tugged down by
the rope on its left.
So it's going to look
something like that.
And it's going to bring the
rope to its right with it.
So the rope will look
something like this.
The rope might look something
like that.
And then I'm going to take this
guy-- this was just an
intermediate position on the
way to being pulled all the
way down here.
So what's the rope going
to look like now?
Well.
This guy, he had some momentum
that got him there.
But then all of that velocity
will essentially go to zero
because he's being tugged
by the rope to the left.
And now, he's going to
switch directions.
And he will have gotten
here, at that point.
The point on the line that was
here-- on the purple period of
time-- it had some
upward momentum.
So it's just going to keep
going, on maybe a slower pace.
It'll be there and it will bring
the rest of the rope to
the right of it with it.
So now my rope is going to
look something like this.
And then finally, where I'm
going to jerk the rope back to
its original position-- so this
left-hand point is going
to be there.
This guy, in the previous
time period,
was moving down rapidly.
So he might get there ready to
switch directions again.
This guy will start
moving down.
This guy, right here, he had
some upward momentum.
So he's going to be up
in this position now.
And he's going to be ready
to switch directions.
So finally, when I've done this
whole cycle, when I've
moved up, down and back there
again, my rope might look
exactly like this.
And I could let go
of the rope.
I could just leave this little
left point right there.
And this the lump is going to
propagate along the rope.
Because in the next moment
of time, what's it
going to look like?
This guy is going to be pulled
up by this left-hand point.
So he'll go back to his
resting position.
This guy's being pulled down
right here by the part of the
rope to the left of him, so he's
going to be pulled down.
This guy's being pulled down.
But this guy had some upward
momentum in the time period
before, so he will
have moved up.
And so, the very next time
period, my rope is going to
look something like this.
And this disturbance in the
rope, if I do nothing else,
and if I don't lose energy to
heat and friction and all
that, it'll just continue
moving down the rope.
If I look at the rope at some
future period in time, maybe
not that far down, the rope will
look something like this.
And if I were to keep watching
it, I'll see this disturbance.
I keep using the word
disturbance, because there's
really no better word
to use for it.
I'll see this disturbance or
perturbation, or whatever you
want to call it, moving
along the rope.
When we think about what a wave
is, we essentially-- I
kind of jumped the gun-- I
keep calling this is a
disturbance, because I didn't
want to use the word, wave. I
want to say, well what
really is a wave?
And a wave really is just this
disturbance that's propagating
down the rope.
So this is a good time to
actually define a wave. A
wave. Because once I define it,
I can start calling this a
wave, as opposed to
a disturbance
propagating down the rope.
So a wave is a disturbance
propagating through space.
And you might see other
definitions of a wave. One of
the most typical ones is
energy or a disturbance
propagating energy
through a medium.
And when they say medium,
it's what is
the wave going through?
So in this example, the rope
would be our medium.
But the reason why I don't want
to use that definition of
a wave is because in future
videos, we'll learn about
electromagnetic waves and those
don't propagate through
any medium.
They propagate through
a vacuum.
So to keep things as general as
possible, we'll just call
it a disturbance that propagates
through space.
And it usually transfers
energy.
What do I mean by transferring
energy?
On this left hand part
of the rope, I gave a
little energy the rope.
I moved it up, down, and
then back again.
And then after I did that, that
up, down, back again is
happening successively
to every point to the
right on the rope.
So if I waited long enough, at
this point on the rope right
here, it's going to move up,
down, and then back again.
Exactly what I did over here
is going to happen to this
point on the rope.
And then later on, it's going to
happen to some other future
point on the rope.
So that energy that I originally
put on the
left-hand side of the
rope is being
transferred down the rope.
If I had some type of object
here sitting on the rope,
maybe when the wave-- when the
disturbance- passes by it,
this thing could get flipped
into the air; it might get
pushed into the air,
and go into a
higher potential energy.
So this disturbance
is transferring
energy in this case.
Now, what I've drawn here isn't
the only type of wave
you can have. I mean my
definition is fairly general.
But the definition is more
general than just what I've
drawn here.
For example, you could have a
sound wave. If you just look
at all of the molecules of the
air, they have some density
that looks something
like that.
And now let's say I had some
type of a membrane-- maybe
it's a speaker--
that jolts this
left-hand side of the air.
So it just pushes-- so let me
see if I can draw this.
Let's say I had some type of
surface here that just really
quickly jolts-- that just moves
it in that direction,
and then just comes back.
So similar to what I did
here, I go up and down.
But instead of doing that, it
just pushes the air and then
pushes back.
So what's going to happen?
Right after it pushes it, the
air molecules that it pushes
up against are going
to jam together.
They're going to
get compressed.
Right here, all these air
molecules that were right on
the surface, they're going to
get pushed next to all these
air molecules that
are right there.
And then when it pushes back,
or when the membrane goes
back, you're going to have
fewer air molecules here,
because you're going to have
a low density here.
And then these guys, that are
all scrunched up together,
they're going to want to get
away from each other.
They might even run
into each other.
And so these guys are going to
run into those guys, who are
going to run into
the next guys.
And so on and so forth.
And after these guys bump into
those guys, those guys are
going to go back to
where they were.
So essentially, you're going
to have this disturbance
that's going to be a set of
molecules compressing, or
bumping into, its neighboring
molecules.
So if you look at this at some
future period in time, all of
a sudden, this area
might look normal.
Let me clear it and draw it
just the way it I started.
So this area might
look normal.
But that compression of the
particles might have reached
right over here.
And not only that, we saw that
right after the compression,
you usually have this area
of low pressure.
So if I were to really draw this
wave, and actually, if
this membrane were to keep doing
it over, and over, and
over again-- so it kept going
forward and back, forward and
back, or right and left, right
and left-- what you would have
is a series of compressions.
The air would just have a
series of compressions.
So that's one compression.
You'd have another compression
right there.
Another compression
And then, in between
the compressions
the air is less dense.
The air is less dense
like this.
And what we've essentially just
generated is a sound wave
travelling through air.
So this right here is a sound
wave. And this type of wave,
where the direction of the
disturbance is the same, or
along the same axis as the
direction in which the wave is
travelling-- the wave is
travelling in that direction--
this is call a longitudinal
wave. So sound waves sound
through air, they're
longitudinal waves.
Sometimes called a compression
wave. Same thing.
Compression wave. Because it's
caused by compression.
Our example of the string, this
is called a transverse
wave. Because the disturbance,
the movement of the medium, is
going in a direction transverse
to-- or at an axis
that's transverse to-- the
direction of our movement.
We're moving in that direction,
to the right.
Actually, our wave is moving to
the right, but the actual
medium is moving up and down.
Our medium is moving
up and down.
That's why this is called
transverse.
While here the medium is moving
left and right while
the wave moves to the right.
So it's along the same axis.
So we're dealing with the
compressional or longitudinal.
Now in this first example,
I just did one cycle.
I just jerked up, down,
and back again.
And I created this
one disturbance.
And we can call this, when you
just do it once, you can view
this as a wave pulse.
If I kept doing that-- if I
just went up, down, back
again, up, down, back again,
and I kept doing it
periodically, over and over
again, then I would generate a
periodic wave. And my
string would look
something like this.
Well actually, it would look
something that right there,
where that's the disturbance
generated from our first time
that we moved this left-hand
part of our string.
So this right here is
a periodic wave.
In the next video, we're going
to talk about a lot of the
properties of a periodic wave.
How the wavelength, and its
frequency, and its period relate
to its velocity, and
all of that.
But I'll leave that alone
in this video.
But I just wanted you to
appreciate what I think is a
concept that we use
in everyday life.
So it's a wave, it's a sound
wave, and all that.
But it's a fairly abstract
notion where we talk about a
wave, we're really just pointing
to a disturbance
that's moving, usually along
a medium, at least when we
visualize it, but not always.
But we're just pointing
to this disturbance.
And this disturbance could take
many forms. It could be a
transverse disturbance if we're
dealing with a string.
It could be a disturbance in
terms of the density of air
molecules in terms of a sound
wave. And there is a relation.
So if you wanted to just plot
the density here by position--
if I were to mathematically
represent this compression
wave right here-- let's say that
this line represents just
resting before the sound
wave hits, that's
just your normal density.
If we were to plot the
density it might look
something like this.
Over here, we have very
high density.
Over here, we have
very low density.
Over here, we have very
high density.
And if you were to plot it, it
would look a lot like that
transverse wave that I did with
the rope at the beginning
of this video.
And that's why they're even
grouped together.
Because mathematically, even
though a compression wave
looks very different, or
you might visualize or
conceptualize it very different
than a transverse
wave, mathematically, they're
essentially the same thing.
You have this quantity.
In this case, it's the density
of the air varying over time.
In this case, it's the height,
or the position, or how much
your displacement from your
resting position-- that's the
quantity varying through time,
that disruption is travelling
over the course of the medium.
That's why we call both
of these things waves.
Anyway, I'll let you go here.
And in the next video, we'll
talk a little bit more of the
properties of periodic waves.